well I can tell you in the last few
minutes this area of mugdoc reservoir
has now been taped off a development as
part of this investigation examining
what happened to 35 year old teacher
Glasgow teacher much love teacher Morel
who lost her life earlier on this week
her body her remains were found inside
the home that she has in Glasgow on the
morning that she failed to turn up to
her job at that school we've heard
tribute after tribute about how much she
was loved how much she was respected but
this is an area of Woodland an area of
reservoir of water that has been now
taped off in the last few minutes
detectives focusing their investigation
and confirming that they are linking
this scene to the death of morel as part
of their investigation and I can also
tell you that just down in the bushes
just ahead of where we're standing there
where a number of officers who were
inside those shrubs and were having a
conversation and shortly after that this
Gordon was put up please let me just
remind you confirming that they are
still looking for a missing man as part
of their inquiries something that is
linked to the death of morel sturrick if
we bring you around here as well just
over in the distance across the road we
can see there a number of specialist
divers inside that vehicle and
specialist equipment well we can tell
you as well that those divers have been
in these Waters this Reservoir over the
course of this morning how is that
forming part of their investigations and
also just up the road here if we spin
around in this direction up the road
there police are searching wooded area
this is a large country park at
Woodlands of more than 600 acres what
are they looking for what are they
examining as they piece together exactly
what happened to this much-loved teacher
well earlier on this morning we spoke to
some parents outside the primary school
where morel worked sandwood Primary in
Glasgow a school in morning and pupils
now receiving psychological help as they
come to terms with the loss of their
teacher
it made them feel very
caring loving
you should just shock sad and then
obviously it's getting cheesy this
suspicious so it's
obviously we're all on about a Lambo and
she treated the kids like our own she
picked him up she had made them have
confidence within themselves she was
just a lovely person yeah she's died
yeah it's really a sad and traged that
mother
she's never going to be a mom of such a
young age of 35 minutes just tragic
parents reflecting there on what has
been a traumatizing few days for them
and their school Community a number of
things still outstanding the identity of
the man that police are searching for in
this country park at this area as I said
taped off in the last few minutes where
we find out exactly what is happening
well we are hoping for an update from
police Scotland detectives later on this
afternoon